e aí a hora de assistir o canal tudo bem
com vocês comigo está tudo ótimo até uma
delícia ouvir falar sobre oi de desculpa
no hoje no rubro negro está muito à
minha volta aqui em casa ea boca aberta
e buscar uma faixa pela embaixada não
muito elevado ou mulher conceito de
sofala em portugal eu vou lá já viu
é o tudo ou nada se sabe
rr rr to deus é que liga já tá ligado
aquele fato naquele diz que a air canada
ea derme devem a um toque no desabafo eu
termino de hoje e terminem de hoje e não
é feita mais a gente eu estou aqui hoje
vai desabafar você tem gente de olho
nele respeito a ninguém a volta mais pra
gente tem um nome não é quanto a um
quinto do ouro ele só encosta dizendo
que tá domingo no ano leva um tapa de um
aceito a senhora como eu olha gente não
é fácil no facebook da minha avó
votei gordo gostei da um planeta como é
que não volta a predominar
ele chega na minha casa vota o que comer
a primeira coisa que faz quando chega na
casa da ópera guto quer ter bakunin no
pé nem a bença à vontade rua eu volto
goldman assinou lei é evitar o pior da
comida na bota câmeras de segurança na
casa da avó tude no brasil e querem ver
alguma imagem
coloca na corrida assim há como falar da
córrego da rua ontem com ação em
cima de informação a gente usa o
facebook briga sim no uso não taiza
daciano nesta exata a que chego na
primeira equipe a importância que o
estado max átila rocha que ok sat
discutem não existem nada e já que tudo
aqui optam por hora das trocas aneme
tudo aqui eu pareça a gente sabe que ele
não é gay não foi lindo
ringo colômbia só o cac exato pedir
desculpa gente não não me apresentei a
vocês não é tão miúda não é apelido dona
miúda não verdadeira voz denir de
modernidade que eu era nova nas pernas
grande do médico interno parecia rico
porque a gente vai ficando velho
a gente vai diminuindo ficando o
coloradinho mm sim e diminuindo
diminuindo diminuindo botar meu nome tão
miúda que a gente quer vem vai passando
o tempo a gente vai tortoni boa na
coluna assim embolam e cada ano e torta
males hoje eu tô com 68 neuton embolando
mais eu tenho coração que errou em bola
também é boa só que quando estiver com
85 não vou virar um pokémon é aquele me
um problema muito grande com o cigarro
nesso hoje não tenho mais o espumante e
debatendo questões como mandante para
ele mas sozinha e reparei de fumar
sozinhas
agora só com cruzou a reclamação que eu
tenho é que filhos o lema da gente que é
avó quando quer passar esta é bruno e
marrone quem é que cuida dos campos a
avó é cão é chamado de cão a pessoa vai
ficando velha ela tem respeito tem moral
pode chamar do que quiser do xingamento
fillon uso correto é cão e japão eu vejo
nato meio em cima do pregão em ano tá aí
isso quando eu não uso do xingamento de
uma vez só me em jataí som e até meu eu
me arrependo de xingar não me sinto que
a minha falecida vozinha que já morreu
faz 27 o trâmite correto chamar o uso de
cão não porque a palavra a palavra tem
poder assim e minha neta não chamo o
povo de nome facebook a palavra tempo
dei a palavra tempo dei a palavra tempo
daremos a falar no entanto é que quando
eu ia bater no primeiro dia de rock in
rio porque o que se lembra da gente na
hora de criar o fidel eixo neto a gente
criar a gente que tem que ensinar um
menino
o que é que as coisas habita o dia d
rone dias e poder feminino que faz vídeo
aqui pra vocês que se tiver de cair e se
é este viaje e meio quando era criança
talvez este jornal no final perto de mim
william bonner foi dizer sim o índice de
aborto cresce mais e mais no brasil é
fica curioso passava eu quero a boca
quando é que eu o levo explicar a uma
criança que é o amor
ele olhou pra mim diz assim disse ao meu
filho o aborto é quando a mãe tarde com
neném ela perde o nenê deu o bota é
quando você perdeu a coisa importante
ele saiu para brincar depois quando já
estava alguém sai andando de carro caiu
na cabeça aí as coisas aí debaixo da
cadeira rede baixo da mesa diz minuto
tem edis não é o que eu acho que eu
abortei minha bola a recomendar o
playbook é uma boa coordenação motora e
eu perdi o controle de conta de tudo eu
perdi o contato adicional de abril
contudo o atleta no meio da sala rapid o
conteúdo banda é meio gol do bota que se
atue o peixe ou espirro fbi se eu peidar
meu caro ao topo pintado activo ativa
não estou nesse negócio que vai regular
o negócio assim aí eu vi na propaganda
que o diabo deixar que tipo diz assim
seu intestino vai funcionar como raj eu
peguei foi pelo medo vai tocar um
negócio a cinco horas da tarde meu baga
pisca 5 6 a 10 horas da noite minha boca
fica bem isso e esse relógio que com 13
horas 14 a 16 horas 20 horas me ajeitar
24 horas não tem banda que a mãe
fisicamente está tudo bem não tá a
coordenação do touro todo lá embora a
gente correr aqui com você sabe que é
essa sim tinha preta na nossa pele
quando teve um ganho essa espinha preta
tendência é essa nossa espinha preta e
assim na casa que é isso não tem como
ser uma treta ramo que você pegou quebra
assim ó começa patatá
você sabe que vai instalar o roubo
o botafogo a equipe passasse ó e no
córrego gordura que estava no corpitcho
pintadinho efeito cai tudo é bom até
acho que é bom pela louça e acaba bush e
pega o peito
vocês pensam que não namora né é um
beijo pode namorar não eu vivo é e acho
que mais namora gente nova e tudo
acusada que sakineh diz a toda hora de
mexer na tsu tem adolescente hoje que
conversará com o time tem que botar o
seu lado de uma camisinha amarrar o saco
de ninguém a vida ainda pelo hotsite nós
não é e frente a frente cara a cara
eu já morei foi muito tímido namorado
que era a melhor coisa do mundo não era
bom porque tinha mal de alzheimer
a gente fazia negócio terminar de fazer
ele quis sequer aquele abraço tom que
tinha outro que gostava dele porque ele
tinha mal de pacs é era ruim é de fazer
um negócio porque ali é mori pax só com
de dormir ficar mexendo assim eu pegava
um deles bota em cima do negócio e khao
san andrés iniesta mas era minha copa do
mundo todo já que 85 onde a mãe né ai
gente abalou a senhora de loulé e hoje
você tá novo mazda que o tempo você vai
ter 70 anos 70 anos não precisam de
respeito é que a educação como a gente
quer que sua avó assim o seu bolso que
você tanto ão a ver você não tem tempo
de visitar seu gol mas com que ele vai
embora daqui então me citar seu novo
time o seu gol e books e ama ele que
estão já vou interagente obrigado eu e
toda vez que escuto humildade dizendo
aqui não sei o que dá um like comendo
não sei que ajudar o bicho que eu gostei
da piada piada mas eu gosto dele então
clique neste link quem diz aí tá muito
obrigado a gente um beijo em nome de
todas as bandas coração de vocês
acho que eu vou pegar uma caixa de pegar
eu falei módulo de memória interna que
chamou pra pegar uma caixa chega lá tem
80 caixas para chutar vai agravando